[Music]
hey rob this is mike from dayton so
here's the premise i won this contest
to have dinner at the pine club
with you and another famous daytonian
so who do we pick
martin sheen
alison janney
or nancy cartwright
and why
thanks keep up the good work
wow i love hearing from my homies and
dayton
and i love me the pine club
i just like waiting in line at the pine
club so the pine club is a steakhouse in
dayton ohio it's an oakwood where i grew
up i grew up all over dayton lived on
the north side also lived in oakwood
but the pine club is an institution and
they're famous for the fact that they do
not take reservations and they really
get off on making you wait uh there's
pictures of like george bush cooling his
heels
while he's president
to get a table that's their thing
um been going there since i was a baby
um there's one person on the list uh
that i don't think you mentioned
jonathan winters
my dad practiced law in the winter's
tower
it was called the winter's tower now i
think it's called something else
um
so i'm gonna go with jonathan winters
um maybe it's because i've had so many
dinners with um martin sheen and allison
janney but uh jonathan winters god rest
him one of the great comedians of all
time
uh but that's a good good row of of of
daytonians there i'm proud to be among
them and um
the only thing is you need to go and
wait for the table and then call me and
then i'll come down i don't want to wait
at the pine club for the table but i
will eat the food
thanks for calling